we finally have a bunch of performance
benchmarks for the new empty Pro and M2
Max MacBook Pros and the results are
very surprising now when Apple announced
these MacBooks they showed off some
performance numbers and typically
companies will try to inflate those
numbers to make them seem as good as
possible that's great for marketing
makes sense but Apple may have actually
underestimated their performance results
now I'm going to show you guys not only
the CP performance also the graphics
performance and a few things that don't
seem to line up which we will talk about
now in our previous videos we showed you
guys the first leaked benchmarks that
were really underwhelming but then it
got better when more tests came out this
of course was for the M2 Max and we got
a result of over 2 000 single core and
14 888 for multi-core but now we are
seeing even better multi-core scores of
fifteen thousand three hundred and
seventy three now one thing that you
have to remember is the M2 Pro and M2
Max have the same exact CPU layout at
least for the unbinned chip so the
performance should be the same at least
for simple tasks like this we'll talk
about tough tasks in just a second but
that gives us a 25 increase in
performance which is a lot better than
we were expecting if Apple stuck with
five nanometer which they did now this
is going to make a big Improvement for
CPU based tasks which there are a lot of
them but unfortunately with these new
benchmarks we do have a downside but
before you guys let you know about that
I have to tell you that we are doing a
worldwide giveaway of a new Macbook Pro
and a Mac Mini and all you have to do is
subscribe enable notifications and
comment down below which you could do on
each of our new Mac videos even the ones
released previously to get more chances
to win we'll be choose using the winner
live on February 1st so don't miss that
video now these new ships have great
multi-core performance but what's
surprising is that the single core
actually went down on these new tests
instead of having over 2 000 we're not
looking at about 1965 in general which
does line up with the regular M2 Chip
now why would that happen if you go and
scroll down here you will see that we
are seeing a base frequency of 3.49
gigahertz compared to 3.68 on the
previous test now there could be a
couple things going on the 3.68
gigahertz we only saw on the 16-inch
MacBooks with the M1 Max but the 14-inch
models did not show that so far with
apple silicon MacBooks the frequencies
have been the same but there's a chance
Apple could allow the 16 inch to clock
higher because it has better cooling now
we also have the hype performance high
power mode so it could be because of
that if it is toggled or simply because
this is on beta software so we're gonna
have to see what the clock speeds are
and we will compare the 14 inch and 16
inch because we ordered a ton of these
things so if you guys want to see real
world performance benchmarks make sure
you guys also have those notifications
enabled now the two thousand dollar 14
inch MacBook Pro which a lot of people
buy and we recommend has a Bend M2 Pro
chip and thankfully we now have the
performance numbers for that there is a
range of scores but we do have some that
are over 12
000 for multi-core which means that even
if you buy the cheapest version with the
bin 10 core CPU instead of 12 you are
getting close to the score of an M1 Max
16 inch expensive laptop now at the very
base level which is really sweet now as
for longer tougher tasks where you can
have throttling we now scores for
cinebench and I want to start out with
the base bin model for two thousand
dollars that's a 14 inch and here we're
seeing 12
489 for cinebench multi-core the crazy
thing is that is exactly the score that
we got with the 16 inch M1 Max the
performance is identical and that is a
very nice boost now if we're comparing
the unbanned version for example a 16
inch model now we have 15
529 that is once again a 25 Improvement
compared to the M1 Pro that's unbinned
or the M1 Max that is a nice gain a year
over a year now the question is how hot
will these machines get and after 10 or
20 minutes will it Throttle Down because
we know with the M2 ship we had about a
30 or 33 gain in wattage in order to get
that performance boost which with that
was actually only 13. so we are going to
test that out Hands-On now one thing I
have to remind you guys is that these
Rob Benchmark performance don't always
translate to real world because many
times there's other improvements that
can make real world performance much
much better and Vadim did a deep dive
into these new Chips covering a lot of
improvements that will affect day-to-day
use so even though this is still five
nanometer we might see some really nice
gains now where it gets really
interesting is graphics and we have
multiple different benchmarks I'm going
to start out with geekbench because we
now have the performance for the both
the M1 Pro and the M1 Max now here's our
score for the M1 Pro this is for the
unbanned model which 19 GPU cores that
we don't yet have the base two thousand
dollar one available but this one gets
691 which is 33 better than the 39 687
that we had with the unbend M1 Pro so it
has once again a nice gain but what's
even more interesting is that the 24
core M1 Max scored 59
345 so the M2 Pro is getting close to an
M1 Max now the M2 Max on the other hand
with the full amount of core scores 86
805. now the best score that we got with
M1 Max was 68 230 so if we do the math
the M2 Max is 27
faster now that is actually lower than
what Apple quoted for the GPU
improvements but we have to remember is
that geekbench does not scale properly
and doesn't actually test these ships
properly because things happen so fast
that the full performance does not kick
in and they're not acknowledging that
they need to change anything but we also
have performance from other tests but
first I want to talk about the Mac
Studio because the M1 Ultra that scored
94 583 and the score of 86 805 for the
M2 Max is also getting dangerously close
in a laptop not a desktop Mac now the
other Graphics Benchmark performance
that we got was gfx Bench which does
scale very well and we have both the Mt
Pro and M2 Max so starting out with the
M2 Pro looking at Aztec Ruins High tier
we have 209.8 FPS compared to 163.5 for
the M1 Pro now that is Improvement of 27
that seems a little bit low and if we
look at Manhattan off screen we have 340
9.4 compared to 272 also roughly 27 28
percent now this was very weird because
when we go and take a look at the M2 Max
performance compared to the M1 Max the
difference is startling for Aztec Ruins
we have 398.5 FPS compared to 281.6 and
that is the difference of around 42
percent and then if we take a look at
the tougher test which is Manhattan we
have 669.6 FPS compared to 435 and that
is a difference of 54 improvement with
the new M2 Max so my guess is that our
first test with the M2 Pro that could
just be a binned version compared to
unbend with the M1 Pro and if that is
the case that means that the cheapest
version of the M2 Pro could beat out the
better version of the M1 Pro and if we
compare the M2 Max compared M1 Max the
scaling works out really well so if your
program is optimized well for metal we
can have improvements of over 50 percent
now how is that the case if Apple gave
us much lower numbers well we previously
showed off that the M1 Max had scaling
issues because of tlb memory not having
enough especially for higher resolution
things and scaling was an issue but with
this new chip people already talking
about that was fixed there's a lot more
buffer the tlb issue has been greatly
improved and that means that not just
looking at the raw numbers but actual
real world performance for higher
resolution tasks especially can be much
better because that bottleneck can be
now removed and what's absolutely
mind-blowing is that if we compare it to
the Mac Studio with the M1 Ultra which
is very expensive you'll see that the M2
Max gets very close in performance with
proper metal scaling we're talking about
almost identical and in the tests that
are CPU limited for example the lower
resolution ones we have 662 FPS for the
M1 Ultra and 962 for the M1 Max it is
smoking it and the same thing for
Manhattan here we have 1700 FPS compared
to 1184 with the CPU and the GPU both
being used and for a lot of tests for
example when we're running raw codecs
both of those are being used so these
machines could actually be a really big
Improvement especially with that tlb
memory issue fixed you guys let me know
your thoughts is this a big enough
upgrade if you guys want to pick one of
these up you can use the YouTube
shopping feature these laptops be linked
below and make sure you guys subscribe
and comment on this video on the
previous ones to get more entries and
check out vadim's deep dive into these
new M2 Pro and M2 Max ships is Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]